hello guys how are you doing today hi
we're doing great good thank you how are
you awesome I'm great thank you I just
want to congratulate you on the new
series it's great so far and uh yeah no
problem I just want to jump right into
it obviously both of you guys have
little musical experience I'd say in
your background but now you're leaving
this series as literal rock stars so I
want to ask you Riley how does that feel
and do I sense a bit of a career shift
on the horizon honestly when I recorded
the album and was rehearsing with these
guys I was kind of like I picked the
wrong the wrong career it's like much
more fun than acting
um
um um yeah I mean it was it was a crazy
Journey for us because neither of us had
ever sang really and or played guitar
um and we came from you know to be
honest we were kind of awful to begin
with and then now we have a record I'm
sorry
I I was
um and and it's just it's incredible we
have like a full record now and it's um
it's you know it's still it's still Mass
just think about it crazy and it's crazy
seeing people you know on the internet
like playing our songs and listening to
the songs it's not something I ever
thought I'd really experienced so it's
wonderful
and for you Riley obviously coming from
a very famous rock and roll family was
it kind of cathartic to step into the
role of Daisy
um it was it was um you know I had a lot
of experience in terms of like I grew up
around a lot of musicians I've been on
tour I've slept on a bus I know what
that world is like I'm very familiar
with it but I didn't really have a
relationship with music in the same way
that the rest of my family has
um I wasn't you know a singer or a
musician so it was really fun getting to
um I don't know have have my own
personal relationship with music
yeah yeah it was great to see and Sam I
want to ask you in your own words how
would you describe the relationship
between Billy and Daisy because it seems
kind of tumultuous to say the least
um yeah I think
um very complex uh um like all the
relationships in the show I don't think
there's one relationship between one
pairing that is is is uncomplicated
um but yeah I mean it's it's I mean it's
a roller coaster ride really I think
from from the initial hatred to the the
fascination the obsession to more hatred
um to love and that you know and but
like that the love kind of transcends
like the creativity to the romantic and
it's sort of wet the Blurred Lines
between the two you know it's just
obvious chemistry uh and tension and
um I suppose this sort of tries to
answer the question of like
is is it is it healthy
um to be in a relationship with your
counterpart
um yeah what's your answer so what was
my answer is it healthy no not billion
days in the 70s no well speaking
speaking of your relationship Sam you're
actually on the record saying that you
were trying not to Fanboy working with
Riley so were you successful or did it
Crash and Burn wow no
out of context add a context no it was
it was because me and me and Riley were
once we were shooting in a diner at the
diner scene and I heard an Elvis song
playing and I had that moment I think it
was the first moment because she doesn't
sort of carry the the that pressure with
her if that makes sense um right and
that was a complex I mean that's a
compliment
um I want to talk more about the fans
yeah yeah so so then I know I think it
was very happy he sunk in I was like
holy crap that's your granddad I said my
granddad is a clown at children's
parties I mean he dresses up as a clown
and he was a paramedic as well but I
mean I remember him as a clown Brillo
the clown yeah that's that's my
grandfather hey not all heroes wear
capes
he wore a nose but not okay yeah yeah
there you go
that's awesome well thank you guys so
much for taking the time and
congratulations on the series I can't
wait to finish it thank you ma'am